which English word has the most
different meanings well in the Oxford
English Dictionary the word with the
most definitions is set for example this
Jello is set and my heart is set if I
can set this set on my television set
Before Sunset will be set and that's
just some of them the word set has more
than 400 different meanings but the
lexicographers at the OED have been
working for years on their next Edition
it's expected to come out in 2037 and
they have found that in the last few
decades a new word has gained even more
meanings than set that word run so far
they have found more than 645 different
senses in which we use the word Run 10
of them are depicted in this graphic
from The New York Times what does the
change mean does it mean we live in a
society where order has been replaced by
motion where what is frantic and where
what hustles is good where we don't just
want sets we want stuff that runs I
don't know but I forgot to set my alarm
I gotta run